hello there I'm Walter Binet dziak and
this is top five with alien covenant
coming out next week I thought now would
be as good of a time as any to dive into
the filmography of its legendary
director Ridley Scott I have a pull up
right now on my twitter at awesome
underscore walter asking you guys with
the next subject on top 5 should be make
sure you go vote and get your voice
heard Ridley Scott is without a doubt
one of the most influential directors of
the last 40 years
his films range from sci-fi horror to
roadtrip movies and everything in
between
jumping onto the scene with his first
feature film in 1977 Scott has built a
legacy that is of undeniable quality the
four-time Best Director Oscar nominee
has had films that quite literally
changed the game for how some genre
movies are made at 79 years old he shows
no signs of slowing down and continues
to pump out films that have become
events to see in theaters these are my
top 5 best Ridley Scott movies number 5
the Martian prior to alien covenant this
was Scott's latest film which came out
in 2015 and starred Matt Damon there was
a lot of buzz surrounding it and that
wasn't for nothing having to leave Mars
in a hurry due to a fierce storm a group
of astronauts leave behind Mark Watney
after he's assumed dead Watney actually
survived the storm and is now stranded
on Mars with very limited supplies on
earth NASA works day and night to try to
bring him home however once his crew
finds out he's still alive they start to
form their own idea for a rescue mission
based on Andy where's 2011 novel this
film proves Ridley Scott still has it I
didn't have a chance to see this in
theaters but after watching it I'm sorry
I missed out as usual the visuals that
mr. Scott puts together are beyond
compare and I'm sure they look ten times
better up on the big screen
Matt Damon playing mark Watney benefits
the film greatly his situation is dire
but the characters positivity and
ingenuity combines for a much more
pleasant and fun viewing experience than
what we could have had with this very
serious premise in the face of
overwhelming
I'm left with only one option I'm gonna
have to science the shit out of this
that's the thing I like most about this
movie it could have been a very serious
affair but its sense of humor from the
whole cast makes it unique from other
space stories that could alienate the
viewer after an overexposure to the
hopeless void of space
you think he means it like are you
kidding me yeah I like are you kidding
it might be the second one
mmm could be the first way the cast is
great here Jeff Daniels Donald Glover
kiewit Elia 4 and Sean Bean that's right
Sean Bean being some of the standouts
and Sean Bean lives Sean Bean lives
seriously though it's awesome to see him
in a big good movement
I want more Sean Bean if you never have
too much Sean Bean the climax of the
Martian is truly spectacular it had me
on the edge of my seat and needs to be
seen just a great movie it's also a
great sequel to interstellar number 4
gladiator this was an epic that
kick-started Scott's partnership of
Russell Crowe and it's packed with
memorable scenes and lines when Emperor
Marcus Aurelius is murdered by his
jealous son Commodus a favored general
of the Roman army maximus becomes a
target of the new Caesar Maximus was to
become the new emperor before Marcus was
killed and after refusing to pledge
loyalty to Komodos he is sentenced to
death after escaping his execution and
fling to his home he discovers his
family dead as Maximus himself it's put
into slavery and his later forced to
fight as a gladiator when his traveling
group returns to the Coliseum in Rome
just going to get this out of the way
first
yes the Pirates of the Caribbean music
is in this movie and yes it is
distracting of course we know the first
pirates movie didn't come out until a
few years after this but it's so
entrenched with that franchise that it
is noticeably distracting when it plays
here
I would be
[Applause]
the rest of Hans Zimmer's music is
possibly one of his best but that just
always stuck out to me now that that's
out of the way gladiator is a hell of a
film a lot of the action and visuals
still hold up and while the movie can
feel dated and toned to other similar
type movies of that period it pretty
much stands on its own as they now
classic larger-than-life tale that may
feature Russell Crowe's most memorable
character detain loyal servant to the
true Emperor Marcus Aurelius father to a
murdered son husband to a murdered wife
and I will have my vengeance the
character motivations are clear and
we're rooting for Maximus from the
beginning Joaquin Phoenix's coma dose is
appropriately creepy any very good foil
to our hero he plays the new Emperor
very over-the-top and it works pretty
well you loved my father I know but so
did I that makes us brothers doesn't it
gladiators brutal action is still
effective 17 years later and possibly
one of the reasons it took home the
Oscar for Best Picture that year
[Applause]
[Music]
gladiator is still a great watch and one
of Ridley Scott's signature films number
three American Gangster
another team-up with crow but this time
with the incomparable Denzel Washington
playing opposite him as real-life drug
lord Frank Lucas for years Frank Lucas
was under the wing of one of Harlem's
biggest mobsters after his death
Frank assumes his spot and starts
bringing in a very potent drug from
Vietnam called Blue Magic with the
success of his new empire rising Frank
brings in his whole family from North
Carolina and builds a power structure
that nearly guarantees his success
meanwhile veteran cop Richie Roberts
sees the changes happening in his city
and is appointed as leader of a special
unit to track down the head of the new
drug problem in New York Russell Crowe
is great in this movie but then they'll
definitely end up stealing the show he's
ruthless and relentless here one of his
best bad guy roles
[Music]
there you go 20% crow also turns in a
very strong performance as Officer
Richie Roberts there separate the
parallel stories happening throughout
the movie build tension from the
beginning copy that already doing to top
bar too high you're gonna find a guy you
murdered him you robbed there's money
then you call me to get you out of it
it makes me an accessory after the fact
motherfucker it's a great crime film
that keeps it leads apart until the end
of the movie when they finally meet the
resulting scene is fantastic I don't
represent nothing but Frank Lucas you
show black businessman like you
represent progress the kind of progress
is going to see them lose a lot of money
with you out of the way everything can
return to normal
this movie is driven by a pair of great
turns from its lead it's also a long
film but it earns that life check it out
if you have it number 2 matchstick men I
just brought this movie up a couple
weeks ago as one of Nicolas Cage's best
performances what's even better than kgs
performance is the movie itself based on
Erik Garcia's novel of the same name Roy
and his partner Frank are con artists
who are very good at what they do as
Roy's prominent OCD starts to worsen he
finds his long-lost daughter Angela and
with his new medication it's symptoms
start to subside when Angela shows an
interest in entering the family business
Roy struggles with keeping his daughter
innocent - his con man crimes or bonding
with her as all this is happening a big
job involving a businessman is a large
enough scam to potentially be dangerous
I feel like this is probably the most
underrated and overlooked Ridley Scott
movie it's got a great story with great
characters and it's just this little
film that I really connected with it's
not a blockbuster or a big grand tale
like some of Scott's better known work
it's very character focused and
character driven with a lot of heart and
emotion that combined with a lighter
tone and result in a great movie never
play somebody who isn't buying what
you're selling you're thinking daddy
daddy what am i selling well what you're
selling is you and the older the better
if you wear up couples you don't want
anyone whispering remarks here about you
and for God's sake make sure the person
Conny isn't calling you a strong part of
the film is its soundtrack and how it's
used at certain points in some cases a
soundtrack that contains too many
well-known songs can be a detriment but
not here Frank Sinatra and Bobby Darin
were definitely used appropriately the
main performances were phenomenal here
especially Nick Cage and Alison Lohman
their chemistry is heartwarming
heartbreaking and so much more love
these two together
Oh
what you did you're not a bad guy you
know you're just not a very good one I'm
sorry I'm sorry I let you down I'll also
say that this movie has a strong rewatch
ability I wouldn't mind seeing it a few
more times in the near future while
introducing it to new people the cherry
on top is that we get to see Nick Cage
totally freaked out in one thing have
you ever been dragged to the sidewalk
and beat for you just to plug bullshit
mom prick the elephant three facts if
you haven't seen this movie I'd
seriously suggest watching it when you
have the chance definitely one of mr.
Scott's best Ridley Scott has four
decades worth of great movies and his
best can't be contained to just five
spots so before we get to number one
here are some honorable mentions
[Music]
and the number one best ridley scott
ruby is alien how could it be anything
else
alien is simultaneously one of the best
sci-fi and horror movies ever made deep
in space the starship Nostromo is
traveling home when its crew is suddenly
awakened from cryo sleep to check out a
distress call on a nearby planet when
one of them investigates a crashed ship
that is the source of the call he
discovers a nest of eggs with living
organisms inside one of them attaches
itself to his face and upon being
brought back on board terror beyond all
understanding begins to engulf the rest
of the crew sets acting effects tone
they all work to maximum effects in this
original alien zone it's an iconic genre
shaping movie that really does have it
all some of my favorite stuff is the
slow build of suspense and atmosphere
I'm not a huge horror movie fan but when
it's done this way I'm always into it
the visuals are some of Scott's best
with frames that just stick with you
long after viewing that ties into how
this film was shot which worked to
perfection especially in how they shot
the xenomorph when it shows us
[Music]
the Becks here are amazing just seeing
most of these practically done made me
appreciate it so much more these kinds
of effects are really a lost art
nowadays I can't lie to you about your
chances you know Zeiss OTUs is one thing
I don't think people mention quite as
much about this movie is the acting the
natural tension that builds up affects
how the characters treat each other and
some of it is very very natural well
let's talk about killing it we know it's
using the air shafts will you listen to
me Parker shut up let's hear it
of course alien has a great payoff and
isn't just all build-up it spawns five
sequels and created one of the most
recognizable alien designs in movie
history
a true landmark movie as with all of
these videos this is a subjective list
I'm sure a lot of you have a completely
different top fiver Ridley Scott and
that speaks to how good of a director he
is narrowing this one down was far from
a simple task as mr. Scott continues to
make quality films my own personal top
five might even need adjusting in the
future I want to hear what you guys
think what is your favorite Ridley Scott
movie leave a comment and let me know
for more content subscribe to my
personal channel youtube.com slash
awesome walter and follow me on Twitter
to take part in more polls about what
may be covered in the future come back
next week when we take a look at five
films that aren't quite up to snuff for
this renowned director
you
[Music]